so i'm interested in modeling the
velocity of an asteroid as it is
entering
the atmosphere so this is the atmosphere
right over here destroying some random
random air particles so we want to
figure out velocity as a function of as
a function of time and we're given a
differential equation to help us model
this
we're told that the rate of change of
velocity with respect to time is equal
to a proportionality constant times 3 v
plus 10.
and so we're actually going to solve
this differential equation use some
actual
data
velocities at particular time to figure
out to figure out the particular
solution to figure out the exact v of t
but before we even do that what do we
what can we intuit about what the value
of k is going to be
well v of t is always going to be
greater than or equal to zero
v of t is always going to be greater
than or equal to zero this has some
positive velocity it's just going to
slow down and eventually come to come to
stop assuming that it doesn't get
disintegrated by the atmosphere so this
is always going to be positive what do
we know have to know about k
well we're clearly slowing down this
thing is going to be this is going to
need to be negative and so if this is
going to be negative and we know that
this thing is over here is going to be
positive then we know k is going should
be negative so let's just can let's just
keep that in the back of our minds as we
try to solve for the particular solution
now to solve for the particular solution
we need some data points and we are
given them
we are told that the velocity at time
zero is in is 30 kilometers per second
so we're going to do everything in terms
of kilometers in seconds
and our velocity at time equal four or
our velocity after four seconds four
seconds after entering the atmosphere is
20 kilometers per second which is in
line with our intuition that we should
be slowing down as time goes as time
goes by as this asteroid has to go
through all the friction
now given the data that i've just given
you what i encourage you to try to do
before i do it is pause the video and
try to find for the particular try to
solve for the particular v of t
and if you need if the numbers get a
little bit hairy try to round them to
the nearest thousandth
so i'm assuming you've had a go at it so
let's see if we can solve this
differential equation
so the easiest thing to start off with
is well let's just multiply both sides
of this by dt
if i do that then this dt is going to
disappear
and it's going to show up on the right
hand side
and then we can divide both sides by 3v
plus 10.
and if i do that
that thing
so that thing is going to show up so i
just divided both sides by 3v plus 10
and multiplied both sides
multiplied both sides by dt
by dt so let me
cut and paste that
so i've just rearranged the terms a
little bit of algebraic manipulation
and now i can integrate this it's
clearly a separable differential
equation i was able to get all of the
v's on one side and i just left the
constant on the right hand side and so
what we can now do is integrate both
sides of this differential equation
so now i'm going to just
integrate both sides
now what is the left hand side going to
be
well i have 3v plus 10. its derivative
is 3.
so
if i wanted a 3 up here i would have to
put a 1 3 over here if i don't want to
change the value of this of the left
hand side and now i have something and
its derivative so i'm kind of um i i'm
essentially going to be doing u
substitution although i'm not going to
go explicitly through all the steps you
could set
u is equal to 3v plus 10 then d u is
going to be 3 3v and so you can
essentially integrate with respect to u
right over here and so you're going to
get one third
one third
times the natural log of and it would be
the absolute value of 3 b plus 10 but
we're assuming that v of t is greater
than or equal to 0. so this thing is
always going to be positive so i could
say the natural log of 3v
plus 10
is equal to the antiderivative of this
is just going to be and actually even on
the left hand side i could have a
constant
so let's just call that c1
and then on the right hand side
if i when i integrate i'm going to get k
times t
k
times t
plus maybe some other constant and we've
seen this show before let's see maybe i
can subtract c1 from both sides in which
case this is going to disappear
and then c2 minus c1 let's just call
that c3 so that'll just be some other
constant as you can see i'm just doing
kind of constant manipulation and let's
see i can multiply both sides by 3 and
then i'll have the natural log of 3v
plus 10 is equal to
3 k t
and then let's see three times c3 let's
just call that c4
c
four this is three i just multiply three
times both sides but it's just going to
be another constant here
and now let's see natural log of three v
plus ten if these two things are equal
to each other then i then e to raise to
each of those powers should be equal to
each other
and so on the left hand side i'm going
to have 3 v plus 10 and on the right
hand side i'm going to have e to the 3
kt plus c4 which is the same thing
which is equal to
exact same thing
as e to the three k t and we've done
this multiple times before
e to the three k t times
e
to the c4
c4 let's just call this thing right over
here c5 another constant this is just
it's e raised to some arbitrary constant
so let's call that another constant so
it's going to be c5
times e to the three k t
e
to the three k t
three k t
now i can subtract ten from both sides
so i'll get three v plus ten
is equal to
all of not 3v plus 10. 3v
is equal to
all of this
so let me copy
so it's equal to
that minus 10.
it's equal to that minus someone's
hammering outside i hope you can't hear
it or at least i guess i hope it doesn't
distract me too much as i'm trying to
power through this and let's see now i
can divide both sides by three
i can divide everything by three and i'm
going to get v is equal to well let's
just call c5 divided by three let's just
call that c
v is equal to c
e
e
to the three k t
three
i only make k in a separate car because
we're going to figure out what k is 3 k
t
minus 10
over 3.
and now we can leverage we can leverage
some of these this these data points we
have to solve for c and k so let's do
that
so the first one is v of zero
v of zero they're telling us is equal to
thirty
and that's going to be equal to when v
when v is e when when t is equal to zero
e to the 3kt is just going to be 1. so
it's going to be c minus 10 thirds
c
minus 10 thirds
minus 10 over 3. let's see 30 is the
same thing as 90 over 3. if you add 10
over 3 to both sides you're going to get
c is equal to 100 over 3.
c is equal to 100
100 over 3.
and now we just need to solve for k and
to solve for k
we can leverage this data point that the
velocity at time equals 4 seconds is
equal to 20 kilometers per second
so we can say
we can say that 20 kilometers per second
is equal to c which is we now know is
equal to 100 over 3
is equal to 100 over three
e
e
to the
let me do this e
to the three k t
e to the three
three times k
times well t now is 4 seconds so i
should just write this as 12 k 3 times k
times 4 is going to be 12
k
minus 10 over 3
minus 10
over 3.
and so let's see 20 we're gonna have to
do a little bit of fractions over here
actually why don't i just multiply
everything times three so i'm gonna get
i'm gonna get 60 and i'll just switch to
one neutral color right now just so we
can ease the amount of time switching
colors so it's going to be 60 is equal
to 100
e to the 12 k
minus 10 i can add 10 to both sides i
get 70 is equal to 100 e to the 12 k
and now i can divide both sides by a
hundred and i'm going to get 7 10
is equal to e to the 12 k
i can take the natural log of both sides
so i get the natural log of 7 10
is equal to 12 k
and then i get
i get k
is equal to the natural log of 7 over 10
divided by 12. and why do you see this
going to be a negative value this thing
right over here is less than e so you're
going to raise e to a negative exponent
to get to it and so this is going to be
a negative value and let's figure out
what that is i'm going to get my
calculator out for this part
so let's see where have we have the
natural log
of seven tens or i could say let me just
actually let me just it's 0.7
and then i want to divide that by 12.
divided by 12
is equal to negative
point zero and i said around to the
nearest thousand so it's point zero
three is zero so let me
let me take that off my screen and now
let me just write it down so k
is and i since i'm rounding let me say
approximately equal to
approximately equal to i already lost my
approximately equal to
negative
negative
this thing is acting funny negative
0.0297
or i could say 0
3
0
if i were to round to the nearest
thousandth and so now we can write our
particular solution to model the
asteroid as it's entering earth's
atmosphere our velocity as a function of
t
is going to be equal to 100 over three
100 over three and i guess in the spirit
of rounding everything to the nearest
thousandth i could write that as 33.333
e
e
to the three times kt
actually let me just do that let me just
multiply
let me just multiply
so three times k
so times
three let me round that to the nearest
thousandth so it's and actually that
makes it a little bit more accurate if i
rounded this in your south i would put
0.90 but then this to the nearest
thousandth is zero or it's
well it would
this this would have been
.090 if i multiplied by three but this
is point zero eight nine rounded to the
nearest thousandth
so let me write that
to the negative
so this part right over here is the
negative 0.089
t
t
and then once again in the spirit of
rounding since i'm rounding this i might
as well just round everything although
this is kind of a more
this is the exact constant so minus
3.333 if i wanted to round everything to
the nearest thousandth
and
we
are
done